The game is changing.
I know I come with a history
that not all of you love.
I'm not gonna get edged out.
♪♪
The game is changing
my job is to ensure
the stability of UBA
Alex, I need you to come back.
You are the only thing
that can save us.
[laughs]
I don't think I've ever said
that before.
♪♪
I'm not gonna get edged out.
Alex Levy.
[applause]
I feel like they're
bringing in my big sister
to clean up my mess.
Man, you couldn't have planned
this any better
stepping away when you did.
I was broken Doug.
Yeah.
Ratings have been down.
This network needs to
clean up it's act.
Five.
We're trying to get ahead
of this coronavirus thing.
-Four.
Someone should cover it.
Well Bradley can do it.
-Three.
Don't forget, this is your show.
And we're back.
-Two.
I know I come with a history
that not all of you love.
One.
Nine months ago you opened a
door
and you need to walk
through it now.
A bombshell from journalist
Maggie Brenner's
upcoming exposé on behind
the scenes troubles
at UBA's The Morning Show.
There is a pattern of behavior
around here
that disadvantages the
people of color.
We need to get our facts
straight.
We need to decide
what the truth is.
Did you hear what you just said?
Maggie, I would like
to see the book.
You don't like me,
you never liked me.
That's not true.
Which part?
Onward and upward.
You were a dynamo out there.
I don't think they're using you
in the right way.
I don't trust her.
-She seems perfectly nice.
Oh God, she bugs me.
♪♪
I'm your boss, I'm gonna
make sure it works out.
Oh, you're my boss.
I thought you were my friend.
I'm on your side.
The network doesn't think you
have the "It" factor
we're looking to showcase
some other talent.
You know what the problem with
racism is?
You don't fix it by pretending
to want to fix it.
What I want is to change things
because the jury's still out
if you were successful.
Happy days are here again.
♪♪
In case you forgot,
I'm the whistleblower.
I'm gonna get everything I want.
You're just so caught up
in ruling
over your rotten little fiefdom
the rest of the world,
they've moved to the cloud
and it is gorgeous up there.
This is a battle for the
soul of the universe.
♪♪